How's it goin' -before this video begins I got an exciting announcement.
Me and Marzia, together for the first time, launched a project together. Our own brand... ....called Tsuki.
I'm wearing one right now. Uh, Tsuki's Japanese for moon of course. We're obsessed with Japan.
It's a unisex clothing brand so it doesn't matter if you're a boy or girl. Or a...
...Creature of the night. -You can still wear Tsuki. We also have some home product as well. It's all ethically made and uh-
It's all designed by us. So yeah one of the items
I really wanted to have was his mock neck -that you got this Tsuki logo on it
Uh, I love this thing. We also launched an oversized hoodie.
Super comfortable, super cool fit on it very unique.
We also got our pink t-shirt with the Tsuki logo along with a cap.
I love this cap so much (finally one that actually fits my damn head).
We even have (if you're feeling very fashion-forward and cool like myself) a beret!
That's right *hehehe*
Bet you didn't expect that. We also have very cool
Tsuki socks along with a Sookie planner, candle (that we selected with the scent) and yeah check it out t-the...
...Stock is limited so, once it's out, it's out. You're gonna... it's now or never basically. So check it out- eh
I'm really proud of it. I'm really proud of me 'n' Marzia finally doing a product together.
It was a really fun thing to do, and hopefully you'll like it as well. (oh baby)
Think we can all agree that YouTube is pretty..
Shi-*OOF*wonderful. YouTube is the greatest of course. What else did you think I was going to say?
*EXTREME WHEEZE COUGH* *slaps table, causing explosion from hidden bombs*
Today I'm going to review YouTube *shht*
Can't even say it.
Today we're going to review some of the finest videos, and some of the finest comments left on the website.
Ya know me-
I care about giving shoutouts to smaller
Channels giving them some hope that day one day could become the next Pewdiepie! What am I talking about?
Moving on all right here, we have a perfect example stop disliking my videos
With Joey Veilleux he can hack you hey the other one
Sorry I'm not your mom oh
No you if you're the one they just might do more videos. I swear. I'm going to fuck you up
I love the angle it's great
If you're the one that dislikes all my videos I swear I'm gunna mess you up!
YouTube truly is a fine place for scholars and gentlemen
Get out of here
Subscribe
disliked
Great, what else fine videos, can you find on this wonderful website?
You can really find anything how to pick up a blue chair off the ground
Mmm seems interesting as well
Hey guys
Thanks for coming a Bluetooth page alright
Today, I'm gonna do a new tutorial
how to pick up chairs fall it falls down
You need is just to lift
The chair does it get up
Just leave it
Thinking
That's like fine chair we have there Allen, but have you seen my chair perhaps
You know this chair basically can't even fall down
YouTube is truly an amazing website, but what really thrives is the community. I'm talking of course about the comments on YouTube
They're the best some of the finest some of the most
Intellectuals on this website stays in the youtube comments. That's how you can find them listening to this from Australia
That's so sick. Thanks for the support. I didn't say I liked it, or he was good, OOP
Sounds like s*** dumba-
Wow it's so great when creators interact with their fans on YouTube truly inspiring Steve. Here's someone decided to upload
Michael Sarah's face
Isn't it great? How people are creative on this website? I'm a kid, I'm nine. I'm nine and a half
shut f*** up
Was a little harsh, but sometimes you got to put fans to place they always try and one-up you with their BS
You need to shut up
LM. Oh nice hacks, how many chromosomes do you have? more than you for sure
Oh, damn! He got roasted!
Damn you don't mess with Wizzy PvP. He's got so many chromosomes. He'll take you back to the Stone Age
Damn like I stuck that guy's hardcore. I'm truly proud to be thriving on this wonderful platform
It feels great. It feels just what I wanted to spend my life on. "Guys, I regret to inform you that
PewDiePie is suffering from cancer
But he doesn't want his subscriers (typo on purpose)
To know because would be too sad for them"
"What no lier" "I am serious, I am his doctor and I
Diagnosed him with it
Sorry :(". "Why does everything bad ever happen to me?!!!"
DOM is of course correct. I he is my doctor. I'm surprised. He leaked is clearly confidential information
No one was supposed to know what was going on with my bawls when he fiddled with them. Don't worry Brett
I'll be fine with or without my nuts
I'll be keep making videos because I just love making YouTube video so much that even if I get a
Life-threatening disease I am NOT going to drop it. I am going to keep on
Grinding, so hopefully it will kill me sooner. "anyone know the song?"
"Yes"
"Thanks" "no problem." Isn't it wonderful where the YouTube community comes together and work together as a team?
Aw, it's truly inspiring
Aw, if only my community would still have for my community is so toxic
Meehhh "me kicking a wall for 12 minutes and 29 seconds
Until my dad tells me to stop" finally someone that could be the next Pewdiepie let's watch
What is this how to basics son does he dad actually Cutler
Oh
Wow
We have found the best video on YouTube guys
We have officially peaked
Congratulations to Leg man you win, this award
Can't wait to see what else leg man is going to make in the future
watched the whole loved it, close enough "come on. I just want to watch black ops 3 gameplay
Make your screen smaller, please"
Stupid ladies get out can this stupid lady gets out of the scene
I need to see those flowers wow are those roses. Is that a super king-size bed
"Who said white people have no culture" isn't it wonderful?
Finally white people have found their culture
Thanks to YouTube. We have something to be proud of "diary 30 Superman is coming to school" "diary 31
Humiliation" let's watch!
Guy: "Good morning
Uhm...i am ready for schoOOl
and uh, these are (?)"
*Switch*
No, I can't watch this
The thing about YouTube is there's an endless ocean of content
But only the best, only the finest rises to the top just look at me
"Anyone else find this scene really hot when this alien farts at jar jar the alien just looked so
Feminine and sexy and the way it farts and turns to him to flaunt it
Like it's inviting him to get closer for the next one
I first watched a movie when I was very young and I have-" no no no!
no a
classic an absolute legendary comment in the YouTube hemisphere
"Be right back Pewdiepie I gotta do my chores"
Where did he go? please Samuel Martinez come back! I want to find Samuel
I want to meet and make a video with him. That would be amazing. I want to know what took him so damn long
"I'm back." Well finally this comment deserves to be framed
It's so it's fantastic an instantaneous
Classic "top 10 things that will happen when Queen Elizabeth dies"
"Big Ben just effing explodes" we don't know that for sure come on
I love I love this because it really encapsulates how over the top that the thumbnails are and if you really?
Process them and really think okay, well, what are they trying to convey here?
Most of the time you just look like an idiot not me though my all my thumbnails are perfect and flawless
Thank you for complimenting me on that "5 fortnite youtubers who have sworn-." Oh my god. No
This is too far. This is why we have the apocalypse happening
Everyone is blaming me for the ad pocalypse
Do you hear me swear? Do you hear me say f- Oof Oof
Ali-a, I am disappointed in you. I thought you were better than that Wow haven't we learned a lot here today
YouTube is truly an amazing website full of wonders and I don't understand why anyone think it's just a Oof hole
Cuz that's not true at all leave a like if you're proud of being part of the YouTube community as well
perhaps check out some of my other videos similar to this one also big
Thanks to YouTube shi- shi- shi- YT shi-
I don't swear. I'm not like those fortnite youtubers.
But I'll let you guess where it came from it's a great Twitter that post similar memes like this one and as always brofist everyone
Bye pewds